we examine the recasting of columbus day
into indigenous people's day dr anthony
fauci continues to preach doom and gloom
and southwest mysteriously cancels
thousands of flights while denying it
has anything to do with pilots sitting
home thanks to vaccine mandates i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to big tech
protect your data at expressvpn.com
ben before we begin first here is your
reminder if you want to feel safer if
you want to keep your home safer your
best choice is ring.com when my wife and
i purchased a home here in florida
moving from california first thing my
wife said get the ring devices on the
house and that is precisely what we did
they're easy to install they make me
feel so much safer about the safety of
my family which is the only thing in
life i really care about with my ring
alarm security system i'm much more at
ease when i'm on the road or away from
home my ring alarm equals peace of mind
protect your home with a ring alarm ring
alarm is a powerful affordable whole
home security system you can easily
install yourself it works seamlessly
with other ring products in one simple
app for a special offer go to ring.com
it's the perfect way to start your ring
experience keep an eye on every corner
of your house with indoor and outdoor
cams see what is happening directly from
your phone protect your home anytime
from anywhere with ring alarm go to
ring.com for that special offer on a
ring alarm security kit today you can
build a system that is right for your
home have it up and running in just
minutes that's
ring.comring.com whenever i'm out of
town i can check in on my property at
all times and keep track of my kids i
love ring it does a lot for me and my
family it'll do the same for you
ring.com slash ben go check them out
right now okay well today marks columbus
day or it has as it has newly been
touted by now the biden administration
and by many major cities around the
country indigenous people's day and it's
worth examining in a little bit of
detail how columbus day has morphed into
indigenous people's day because this
really i think may have been the first
step in the united states
toward the dissolution of sort of
national monuments what i mean by that
is that there are monuments that had
been argued over for a long time because
they honestly ought to be super
controversial so for example confederate
monuments you understand exactly why
people would look at that and go why
exactly is their statue of a person who
rebelled against the united states you
get that right you understand that and
certainly you see from a black american
perspective why you would look at a
confederate statue and say to yourself
well that person literally has a statue
for fighting for the enslavement of my
ancestors right the confederate statue
is not a statue to
uphold the glory of the united states
it's a statue about people who are
legally speaking traitors
and you understand the countervailing
argument which is that
we have to actually recognize the
ugliness of our history in order for us
to move forward and tearing down those
statues is a mistake that obliterating
history in any of its forms is generally
a mistake that's the position of
conolisa rice okay and then on the other
end of the spectrum statues that should
not be torn down you have statues of
george washington which over the last
few years have been hit with red paint
you've seen statues of george washington
torn down you've seen actual american
heroes being obliterated
and the idea there is that virtually all
american heroes participated in crimes
and injustices of their time meaning
that were very common at the time and so
most americans look at those people and
they say okay what were their historic
contributions to the united states
versus what were their demerits of the
time not meaning if there were a person
who did what george washington did today
what would we do to that person that
person would go to jail slavery is
illegal for example but in the context
of the time when slavery was near
universal across
virtually all of the world what did he
do that was good what was different
about george washington that was what
was the same as his compatriots okay
well when you look at christopher
columbus which has now become sort of a
hot topic when you look at christopher
columbus which is he closer to george
washington or a confederate monument
is he closer to a person who did
something truly kind of amazing and
heroic but participated in the evils
that were very common to his time or is
he someone who's predominantly
characterized by his evils
so for most of american history the
answer was pretty obviously the former
and christopher columbus did something
unbelievably heroic right he did more
than any of us have done he got on a
boat he crossed a giant ocean that had
not been mapped
and he proceeded to find hispaniola on
behalf of the west right he found cuba
on behalf of he landed in the bahamas on
behalf of the west
and this was considered a pretty damned
brave thing he had to go to multiple
different countries in order to find
funding for his voyage he had to somehow
withstand mutinous sailors who got about
three quarters of the way there and
they're like we are in the middle of
nowhere would you like to turn around
now
to to
kind of shortchange what columbus did
is
not only a historic mistake but reveals
a certain level of historical ignorance
because it's kind of an incredible feat
just on the face of it and you don't
have to deny any of columbus's sins or
the sins of the people of the time in
order to recognize the historicity of
the feat the historic importance of the
feat because the fact is that opening
the north american continent to the west
has paved the way for the united states
which of course is why we celebrate
columbus day right benjamin harrison was
the president of the united states when
columbus day was declared an official
federal holiday in 1992 and he wrote a
proclamation encouraging americans to
mark the 400th anniversary of columbus's
voyage he said on that day let the
people so far as possible cease from
toil and devote themselves to such
exercises as may best express honor to
the discoverer and their appreciation of
the great achievements of the four
completed centuries of american life
right it was the discovery that was
being celebrated not columbus's
treatment of the natives the discovery
now the reason again this is important
is because when we look at history we
have to look at what made the person
different not what made the person the
same as all the other people who are
doing evil things at the time okay so
over the past couple of decades
particularly there has been the rise of
something called indigenous people's day
which is a celebration of the people who
are here before columbus now i have no
problem with a day celebrating the
culture and achievements of people who
are here before columbus but to put it
on columbus day is very specifically
political in fact if you wanted to have
an indigenous people's day and you
wanted to have it coincide with for
example an american holiday the better
holiday to do that would probably be
thanksgiving considering that
thanksgiving is a day when native
american peoples actually helped the new
european settlers on the continent i
mean this is why when you were growing
up the way that this was celebrated
thanksgiving in school is some of the
kids would dress up as squanto and some
of the kids would dress up as pilgrims
and they'd all have lunch together
and if you want to celebrate the
contributions of indigenous peoples
typically you don't do that
on the day that is dedicated to the
discovery of the americas by the west
right if you want to have an indigenous
people the only reason to have
indigenous people's day on columbus day
is to specifically hone in on the
supposedly unique evils of christopher
columbus or of the west discovering the
americas
in sort of the same way that you will
see the
you'll see the arab population in israel
commemorate quote-unquote knock by day
on the foundation of the state of israel
right the idea being that the state of
israel was the destruction right the
state of israel is the bad thing it's a
disaster right this is what indigenous
people it's it's a zero-sum game when
you decide to place indigenous people's
day on the same day as columbus day it
doesn't have to be a zero-sum game you
could have columbus day celebrating
columbus and then you could have
indigenous people's day celebrating
indigenous peoples they don't have to
occupy the same day but there is a
reason they occupy the same day and the
reason they occupy the same day is
because of an attempt to twist american
history into a long procession a long
procession of abuses and evils
unending even until today
the case for indigenous peoples day on
the same day as columbus day is
basically the 1619 project you're just
calling it the 1492 project the idea
being that american history is just a
long train of abuses it began in 1492
and it has not ended today
i would say a lot of the roots of
indigenous people's day lie in the
historian howard's inn for those of us
who are following the debate over
critical race theory and the teaching of
history in the schools the truth is that
critical race theory being taught in the
schools is sort of the second wave of
radicalism being taught in the schools
the sort of howard zinn version of
american history where america is
indubitably bad top to bottom howard
zinsman was pushing that back in the
1970s and on
and that's had a pretty market impact
because now indigenous people's day is
being celebrated from the white house to
pretend that there is no ideology
attached to this is to ignore the actual
history of indigenous people's day if
you look at history.com for example
they talk about the fact that the
original controversy over columbus day
was actually a nativist okay because
there were a lot of people in the united
states who didn't like catholics and
they thought that honoring columbus was
honoring catholics okay but says
history.com in recent decades native
americans and other groups have
protested the celebration of an event
that resulted in the colonization of the
americas the beginnings of the
transatlantic slave trade and the deaths
of millions from murder and disease okay
so number one to pretend that
colonization between tribes didn't exist
before the west got here or that the
slave trade didn't exist before the last
got here and there wasn't an official
transatlantic slave trade obviously but
there was certainly a ringing and robust
trade of slaves or at least slavery
happening enslavement of of captives
happening routinely across the the
americas before the west ever got here
the deaths of millions from murder and
disease right is what they say
millions of people died from murder and
disease in the americas long before
christopher columbus ever set foot on
hispaniola
right it's it's being treated as a
zero-sum game so for the white house to
sort of embrace the zero-sum game is
indicative of just how deeply rooted
this ideology is and i want to get
deeper into what the ideology means in a
second here's jen saki saying that it's
very important to this white house to
commemorate indigenous peoples day not
as sort of a a generalized thank you to
native americans for their contributions
to the united states and also for their
contributions to world history but
instead to do it directly on columbus
day
well today is both columbus day as of
now and this is why you're asking the
question as well as indigenous uh
people's day i'm not aware of any
discussion of ending that uh either of
ending the prior federal holiday at this
point
but i know that recognizing today as
indigenous people's day is something
that the president felt uh strongly
about personally he's happy to be the
first president to celebrate um and to
make it um
the the the history of moving forward
okay so why exactly are we tying these
two things together okay the answer
obviously is that the upside for the
west is the downside for everybody else
and this is the this is the general
howard zinn take on american history so
howard zinn was a professor at boston
university he wrote a very bad book
called the people's history of the
united states it is cribbed from a bunch
of other sources frankly and it's filled
with a lot of pseudo-history zinn was a
communist and so a lot of his or at
least a communist fellow traveler and so
much of his writing is rooted in an
almost soviet view of american history
as just completely evil top to bottom
dominated by capitalist rapaciousness
in in this view i mean howardson talks
openly about this the idea was that
european dispossession of native
americans is the root of property rights
right the property rights are bad that
was the problem that underlying the
evils perpetuated by columbus against
native americans were property rights
and property rights are inherently bad
because again howardzin was a communist
fellow traveler a traveler so howard's
in i mean i write about this in my not
the latest book but the one right before
how to destroy america in three easy
steps i write about this they say howard
zinn opens his masterwork by contrasting
the arawaks of the bahamas islands who
he says were quote very much like
indians on the mainland who were
remarkable european observers were to
say again and again for their
hospitality their belief in sharing with
the evil europeans who were quote
dominated as it was by the religion of
popes the government of kings the frenzy
for money that marked western
civilization and its first messenger to
the americas christopher columbus and so
that's the contrast the contrast is the
sort of russonian noble savage notion
that everybody who was living in the
americas before the west got here was
wonderful and it was kind of pocahontas
and the disney movie and then the west
got here and it was all rape and
capitalism in this narrative columbus
was merely western brutality writ small
the natives by contrast were quote the
ideal of humanity quote columbus and his
successors were not coming into an empty
wilderness but into a world where human
relations were more egalitarian than in
europe and where the relations among men
women and children in nature were more
beautifully worked out than perhaps any
place in the world right this is what
howard's in writes
now
begin with this even if that were true
the even if it were true that everything
was wonderful in the new world and then
columbus came here and this was somehow
a representation of the evils of
property rights what that would
demonstrate is not the evils of
capitalism it would demonstrate the the
evils of seizing land from people which
is actually not capitalism
but the more important argument which is
which zin's argument that america was
sort of born in sin and is thus
irredeemable
unless you just get rid of property
rights is is really silly okay the
reality of course is that you don't have
to minimize the brutality of european
treatment of native americans to
recognize that the russonian vision of
what america was before the west got
here is just not true
harvard stephen pinkler pinker says
quote contra leftist anthropologists who
celebrate the noble savage quantitative
body counts such as the proportion of
prehistoric skeletons with axe marks and
embedded arrowheads or the proportion of
men and a contemporary foraging tribe
who died at the hands of other men
suggest that pre-state societies were
far more violent than our own
but that of course is the entire goal
the idea is the west is uniquely bad and
everything was before in order to
contrast what happened before the west
is uniquely good
now that of course is not true human
evils tend to be pretty common to pretty
much all the humans
and again the the basic notion that
everything was sort of hunky-dory on the
continent before the the west god here
is is also not true i mean there was
vast enslavement of of other warriors by
tribes there was not by the the native
americans that columbus dealt with but
there was apparently uh a tribe that had
been
engaging in in cannibalism that was sort
of nearby and had been actually preying
on the taino according to according to
the most recent sort of scientific
estimate
the notion here is not to justify
anything that columbus did that was bad
against native americans the point here
is that all of human history is replete
with evil
when we pay tribute to people what we
are paying tribute to is the good that
they did not the evil that they did and
to pose those two things in direct
contrast as though what you have to do
is choose between columbus day and
indigenous people's day by putting them
on the same day as though they are the
flip sides of one another or as though
indigenous people's contribution ended
when columbus got here is also very
silly
you can pay tribute to columbus and then
if you want to pay tribute to indigenous
peoples you can do that on a different
day it doesn't have to be the same day
the reason that it was done on the same
day is because again the idea was that
what was good for the west was bad for
everyone else because the west is
inherently kind of bad
and that is untrue
but but that idea has led to some pretty
bad law actually
like it's kind of fascinating
and there is something called the indian
child welfare act that is still on the
books in the united states and it
actually harms native american children
but again it's predicated on the idea
that we have to
treat people in different ways based on
race which is which is a mistake
which was in fact the mistake of
columbus as it turns out we'll get some
more of this in just one moment first
let us talk about a simple fact and that
is right now it is really hard to find
good employees i mean we have 10 million
open jobs people are not filling them
how are you going to go about filling
that open employment slot well the
lockdown's the last year and a half have
created all this pent up demand you need
the best place to find those employees
that of course is ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on zip
recruiter they send your job to over 100
top job sites while giving you access to
their network of millions of job seekers
zip recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and then proactively
presents them to you you can easily
review recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
which encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates zipper crews technology is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post unzip recruiter get a
quality candidate within the very first
day right now you can try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e just head on over to
ziprecruiter.com slash daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire now removing history from from its
context is one way of uniquely
condemning a civilization and that is a
huge enormous mistake and when it comes
to doing good for native americans today
we do a lot in this country that is
rooted in sort of symbolic attempts to
appease native americans for example and
it doesn't do anything for actual native
americans on the ground so for example
we had a big debate over the washington
redskins and removing the name and
calling it the washington football team
and all this or the cleveland indians
changing the name of the team
right the idea is that that is
inherently insulting which again i find
kind of bizarre because if you ever
called the team the cleveland jews and
they went around beating up the new
orleans saints i'd be like wow this is
kind of great but in any case
the the idea is that we have to the the
best way to pay tribute to particular
racial groups in the country is to
is to worry about their sensitivities as
opposed to making their lives better and
the reality is that if you wanted to
make lives better for native americans
living in the united states you'd worry
a lot less about columbus day and quote
unquote indigenous people's day and
you'd worry a lot more about the state
of play in native american reservations
which are disproportionately suffering
from poverty and joblessness
and we've constructed laws that make it
worse for those people there's a really
interesting article in the or in the
orange county register by a guy named
timothy sandofer
who's vice president for litigation at
the goldwater institute and he talks
about something called the indian child
welfare act
he says more than a dozen states have
recently chosen to recognize the second
monday in october not as columbus day
but as indigenous people's day in an
effort to acknowledge the nation's
indebtedness to native americans as well
as the many injustices they've
experienced over the centuries it's
fitting that the supreme court is now
poised to consider a case involving one
of the greatest injustices ever
inflicted on native americans the case
involves a federal law called the indian
child welfare act icwa which effectively
bars states from protecting native
american children from abuse and denies
them opportunities to find permanent
caring adoptive homes enacted in 1978
with the goal of preventing state child
welfare agencies from taking children
away from native american parents on
insufficient grounds icwa went too far
in the other direction
icwa categorizes children as indian
based exclusively on biological ancestry
even kids who are not tribal members
speak no tribal language and have never
lived on a reservation qualify because
they are quote unquote eligible for
membership because of blood ties
then the act imposes a separate set of
rules whenever state courts review cases
involving their safety and those rules
are way less protective than those
applied to other kids for example if a
white or black kid is abused by a parent
the state can take her into protective
custody as long as it first makes quote
reasonable efforts to preserve the
family unit this is not required if
aggravated circumstances exist like
molestation or drug addiction but the
icwa requires active effort a term the
law doesn't define but which is more
demanding than reasonable efforts and
this is not excused by aggravated
circumstances this means state agencies
must return indian children to families
they know are hurting them the results
are often tragic montana officials knew
anthony renova was being abused so they
placed him in foster care for four of
his five years of life had he been
non-indian he might have been adopted
instead thanks to icwa the state was
forced to return him to abusive parents
in february 2019 and nine months later
they beat him to death
the icwa requires that indian children
be adopted by indian families instead of
families of other races because there
are not a lot of indian families looking
to adopt native kids in need are often
bounced from foster home to foster home
never finding a permanent home you
remember that there was a pretty famous
case recently in which there was a
foster home where the foster parents
wanted to adopt a native american kid
native american kid had never met his
native american relatives the courts
refused to allow the foster parents who
had known the kid for years to adopt the
kid because of the icwa
in other words very often the policies
that people on the left think are going
to help native americans very often
actually hurt native americans
but the goal is symbolic here i
understand that the reason that we've
transferred over from columbus state to
indigenous peoples day is not really
about helping native americans it's
about the symbolic notion that the west
is inherently bad and that the sins that
the west participated in which were
participated in by virtually all
civilizations of the time including
civilizations that
were present on the north american
continent when columbus got here
the idea is that columbus's mere arrival
was the worst of all the things
right that he had somehow changed the
nature of the game in terms of in terms
of disease or murderousness or all of
the rest
this is why you get all the claims that
are made in schools now colleges that
christopher columbus perpetuated a
genocide that is not true a disease
kills lots of people
the german theory of disease was
certainly not
in knowledge in
and as it turns out there was disease
that had been killing native americans a
lot longer than that because disease is
a universal to the human experience
and the point of all of this is is again
not to downplay the contribution of
native americans whose contributions
particularly in the northeast of the
country at the foundation of the united
states can be seen in some of the
documents even of the time
nor does this downplay native american
culture is to point out that when you
treat history as a zero-sum game what
you end up doing is placing modern
people who live today in direct
opposition to one another and you end up
undermining the roots of a civilization
that has provided great prosperity for
enormous numbers of people including
native americans on the continent of the
united states living today right that
does not mean the justice the injustices
of the past are excused it does mean
that if you're gonna look at history and
context you have to actually be
responsible about it you can't pretend
that only the bad exists or that
the the good that was done by columbus
arriving on the continent is outweighed
by a bad that was universal to the time
if you do that there will be no statues
of anybody left in history because as it
turns out
pretty much every hero that we have
anywhere throughout history has
committed sins that were universal to
the time in 200 years all the people we
consider heroes today will be considered
villains for a wide variety of new
reasons that will have cropped up over
the
next couple of hundred years every
single person who we're building a
statue to today will be that'll be torn
down 100 years if this is the logic that
you hold to because again human beings
are complex we have our upsides and we
have our downsides and it's very
important to recognize our contributions
not just the villainy that was universal
to the time and that then had victims
attached to it meanwhile
the the
attempt to control everybody
throughout this coveted pandemic
continues a pace and it does have some
pretty significant downsides so dr
anthony fauci the greatest of all
doctors i'm sorry dr joel biden is the
greatest dr anthony pouch is the second
greatest dr
dr fauci he continues to just panic
people
over and over but the idea is that the
vaccines work but also they don't work
the vaccines are very good except when
they are bad
you're vaccinated which means you don't
have to worry except you have to deeply
worry and this is why we have to use
mandates and this is why we have to
control things top down
right this is the smiling face of
authoritarianism via your public health
establishment dr anthony fauci why
they're still trotting him out when he
really has no institutional credibility
with precisely the people he is supposed
to be talking to right everybody who's
vaxxed and everybody who trusts fauci
already is going to get vacs triple x
quadruple vac squint pupil dexed right
whatever fouch he says but there's a
whole group of americans who are not
getting vaxxed and many of them aren't
doing it specifically because they don't
trust fauci
they trust that
frankly i i doubt as well i am i do not
trust dr fauci i think that he has been
wrong on nearly every issue of the
pandemic sometime during the pandemic
and i think that he is a political
catzpal of the biden administration will
do whatever they say no matter whether
they are doing so rooted in politics or
whether they are doing so rooted in some
sort of science okay so over the weekend
he said it is tough to predict when
vaccinated people can go indoors without
a mask the answer is now if you're
vaccinated you can go indoors without a
mask
the reason i say that you can do this is
because i don't care whether you get
sick from covert i care whether you get
hospitalized and die from covet
i didn't care whether you got sick from
the flu i didn't care whether they got a
cold i didn't care about nearly like
this is the first disease in human
history that i'm aware of where we care
deeply about whether you contract a cold
and a slight fever for a day or two
because that is what you will get if you
are vaccinated by and large and yet dr
anthony fauci is saying it's tough to
predict when vaccinated people can go
indoors without weird because i went
indoors without a mask like you know for
the past six months strange and
everything's been fine and so is
everybody that i know because we don't
live by the
mewling
tyranny of dr anthony fauci
how long do you think it will be until
it's safe for vaccinated people to once
again be indoors without a mask it's
always tough to predict that i think if
we continue to go down in the cases that
we're seeing right now and more and more
people get vaccinated as the dynamics of
the outbreak namely the amount of virus
circulating in the community goes down i
hope we'll be able to pull back on some
of those restrictions to get closer to
what we really feel is normal in the
community
so let me just point out for dr anthony
fauci that um you are safe right now
when he says
we have to we we can't determine when
it's safe no you can the vaccines are 80
to 90 percent effective against
hospitalization and death and that means
that your death rates are probably lower
than that of the flu depending on your
age stratification and significantly
lower than than you know
driving in a car typically right so um
you can go inside without a mask but
he's going to continue this right we
have to continue this so here's fauci
saying maybe we'll be discussing
mandates for travelers
on the table is the issue of mandates
for vaccine it's always discussable we
always wind up discussing do you support
it but right now i don't see that
immediately you know dana i don't want
to say support or not i think it it's a
decision that's made by input from a
number of parts of the government
including public health
okay let me just point out there's no
necessity for this throughout the
pandemic the evidence that this thing
was being spread on planes was basically
none since the beginning because these
planes have hepa filters they have
better air circulation than you
typically have in your home like by a
long shot
basically the two places be two places
safest places to be by the statistics
during this pandemic we're either
outside in open fresh air or on a plane
right there there's i'm unaware of any
evidence demonstrating that chief
vectors of transmission were airplanes
and yet here he is saying that maybe we
should have travel bans on people who
are not maybe we'll consider that what
is he talking about the caseload in the
united states has been dropping rapidly
for the past several weeks
but panic is the entire thing here's the
thing you are now going to run into
resistance it is not just in the united
states it is international you are going
to run into serious resistance across
the board
according to the uk daily mail hundreds
of thousands of u.s service members
remain unvaccinated or are only
partially vaccinated against covid as
the deadlines to do so nears
about 90 of the active duty navy is
fully vaccinated 72 percent of the
marine corps are the army has 81 percent
of its members vaccinated more than 60
000 people in the air force still need
to do so here's the thing those may
sound like high percentages but if the
mandate is you are dishonorably
discharged or you get vaccinated and
you're about to lose somewhere between
15 and 20 of the entire armed services
of the united states
in the middle of a confrontation with
china for example
are you out of your damned mind
according to the daily mail there are
almost 340 000 such military personnel
the two percent who haven't been jabbed
at all represents close to 7 000 people
there are 51 000 members of the active
marine corps personnel who have yet to
have the jab
both branches have to be fully vast by
november 28th
the rate is worse for members of the
army national guard and the army
reserves which have until june to meet
the vaccination requirement
military officials are hoping that the
vaccination rates will
will boost
but
again
typically these are young healthy people
who are in the military and a lot of
them are saying to themselves is this
something that i desperately need to do
is this something i desperately want to
do now listen there are all sorts of
health mandates i'm being in the
military although we've been
increasingly getting rid of those we got
we moved down the bmi and we and we've
decided that we're going to lower
physical standards for entrance into
various branches of the military because
we have to make sure that there are more
women who are being recruited in all of
this but
with that said these vaccine mandates if
you end up taking 10 to 15 of the
military off the board how is that going
to work out for the country we're seeing
how it's working out for southwest so
right now
southwest airlines has canceled 1800
flights over the weekend
disrupting the travel plans of thousands
of customers and stranding flight crews
they are blaming the meltdown on a
combination of bad weather air traffic
control and its own shortage of
available staff
now
the southwest pilots union
they are saying that um they are are not
doing this is not a result of their
attempt to fight back against the
vaccine mandates because right now the
southwest union has a lawsuit against
the airline attempting to put in place
an injunction
to to stop all of this
okay and so they are i think a lot of
the unions right they have union
contracts they're still supposed to show
up and so they're doing what would be
called in sort of police or teachers
parliament's a sick out and this is the
theory is that many of these pilots many
of the staffers are saying listen if you
continue with this mandate thing i'm
just gonna take my six days now right
we're all gonna take our sick days at
the same time we're gonna we're just not
gonna go to work and then we'll see how
it works out for you the rates
on cancelled flights for southwest over
the weekend or something like 28 as
opposed to two or three percent for
other airlines
i know this is an incredibly difficult
time for all of you and our customers
are not happy alan casher executive vice
president of daily flight operations
told staff in a note on sunday
the airlines had initial problems were
bad weather and an faa imposed air
traffic management program
they said although we were staffed for
the weekend we could not anticipate the
significant disruption that was created
from unexpected atc issues and bad
weather across our florida stations now
i'm a little confused by that because i
live in florida and let me tell you the
weather was not uniquely horrifying over
the weekend
in fact the weather yesterday was
actually very nice
the federal aviation administration said
there were a few hours of flight delays
on friday afternoon because of severe
weather and staffing issues at
jacksonville air route traffic control
center which controls airspace in five
parts of alabama georgia florida north
carolina and south carolina they said no
faa air traffic staffing george
shortages have been reported since
friday the faa said
some airlines continued to experience
scheduling challenges due to aircraft
and crews being out of place
now again the dallas-based airline
canceled over a thousand flights on
sunday that is 28 of its entire schedule
after canceling 800 flights on saturday
american which operates a hub in miami
canceled only 66 flights
or two percent of its operation last i
checked miami is also in florida spirit
airlines which is legit the worst
airline canceled 32 flights four percent
of its schedule
so there were staffing shortages that
fueled hundreds of cancellations and
delays at southwest over the summer
because southwest basically ramped up
the the flights that it was booking
before they had all of their staffers
back
the airline had to trim its schedule
after the summer to avoid further
disruptions
but
with that said
the the vast lack of flights was leading
a lot of people to suggest that maybe it
was just people who are calling out sick
because the covered vaccine mandate a
southwest spokesperson said quote it's
inaccurate there's a lot of unfounded
rumor and speculation circulating the
southwest airlines pilots association
the labor union they said we can say
with confidence our pilots are not
participating in any official or
unofficial job actions is that our
pilots will continue to overcome swa's
management's poor planning as well as
any external operational challenges and
remain the most productive pilots in the
world
earlier on sunday the union said the
company's announcement last week it'll
join other airlines and complying with
the biden administration requirement is
contributing to distractions for
aviators they said well make no mistake
about it due to months of staffing
issues and inefficient scheduling
practices we have been operating at a
higher than normal operational risk it
said reports of fatigue which require
pilots not to fly are triple historic
norms
instead of all of these challenges have
led to added distraction in the cockpit
this week's coven 19 vaccine mandate
announcement by the company only
exacerbates the situation well i mean
you can either think that it's a
coincidence or not a coincidence that
the week after southwest announced the
vaccine tape 30 of flights get cancelled
on the weekend maybe it's maybe it's
coincidence maybe it is not
blaming it on
extraneous circumstances seems somewhat
suspicious given the fact that very few
of the the other airlines are
experiencing like none of the other
airlines are experiencing anything close
to the flight delays and cancellations
that southwest has seen
we have been speaking here at the daily
wire to people who work for southwest
off uh you know we're speaking on
background with them and what they're
saying is that employees from all areas
are using built up sick time to try and
get ahead of being fired by the vaccine
mandate
southwest has not been offering a covet
testing option they're federal
contractors they say so they are not
allowed to
there are rumors that air traffic
controllers and amtrak other
transportation transportation services
might do the same soon and some pilots
are filing aviation safety action
program reports to the faa claiming
unsafe flying conditions in the cockpit
because so many pilots are concerned
about losing their jobs because
basically if some pilots lay off that
means the flights either get delayed or
some other pilot has to take over
so
it turns out that forcing people to do
something they don't want to do has some
pretty dire consequences or may have
some dire consequences by the way this
is not unique to the united states
in israel which has unbelievably high
rates of covered vaccination young
people are largely refusing to get the
third covet booster so israel has
decided that in order to have a vaccine
green card you need to have a coveted
booster shot you have to have a third
shot now israel is unique in this
respect i'm not aware of any other
country where they are saying that
everybody has to have a coveted booster
shot a third shot in order to be given
some sort of green card
okay and young people are largely saying
nope
only a quarter of 16 to 19 year olds in
israel according to the wall street
journal have received a booster along
with 40 to 20 40 of 20 to 29 year olds
and 47 percent of 30 to 39 year olds
okay so a minority of people under the
age of 40 who are eligible for the shots
have gotten the booster at this point
tamar herman who's been conducting
opinion polls on vaccine policy at
israel democracy institute says quote
younger people are less afraid of covet
some are confused and bewildered whether
they're really at risk or it's part of
the government propaganda
on monday europe's top health regulator
recommended boosters for anyone 18 and
over who'd received their second shot of
the vaccine developed by pfizer and bio
and tech the uk has begun providing
boosters to anyone over the age of 50.
the us is offering them to anyone in
their 65s and up
but in israel some younger people say
they're being coerced into having the
third shot
i mean a lot of people feel this way
especially because again the third shot
is basically driving up antibodies so
that you don't get infected but it is
not actually
really radically raising the rate of
prevention against hospitalization and
death which again is the thing that you
care about most
basically all of the public policy
interventions are now creating massive
economic turmoil downstream we'll get to
that in one second first let us talk
about the simple fact that your sleeve
quality matters to you and that means
you really care and you should care
about the sheets that you're putting on
your bed bullet and branch knows high
quality sleep does not stop your
mattress their ultra soft organic sheets
are transparently sourced and produced
in safe fair conditions you will feel
the difference and you will know that
you're making one
the signature hem sheets are beloved
bestsellers for good reason they get
softer with every wash they're buttery
soft lightweight and 100 organic cotton
sateen weave that is perfect for all
seasons they're made to a higher
standard with toxin-free processes and a
fair trade certification to ensure
workers are paid fair living wages
partners and customers are at the center
of every choice the company makes
bulletin branch partners with
family-owned businesses that align with
the same values and standards and we
have bowling brand sheets at our house
in fact they are so good we got rid of
all of our other sheets like after
you've slept on bowling branch it kind
of ruins other sheets for you they're
just that comfortable experience the
best sheets you've ever felt choose bull
and branch you can try them worry free
for 30 nights with free shipping and
returns and my listeners get an
exclusive 15 off your first set of
sheets with promo code shapiro at bull
and branch dot com that is bull and
branch dot com b-o-l-l and branch dot
com promo code shapiro
all right we'll get to more in just a
moment first it's not often you can say
one man changed the course of history in
a positive way today we do remember one
man that did the great navigator and
fearless explorer christopher columbus
man whose bravery persistence and skill
helped create the america we know and
love it today that is why despite the
anti-history peddled by the left to
smear the great italian navigator we're
going to celebrate him columbus unlocked
the greatest continent for the west and
we are letting you unlock the greatest
content online for 35
off today only just head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe enter code
columbus to get 35 percent off and
celebrate a legend who made the greatest
continent american tomorrow tuesday
october 12th we are taking backstage to
an entirely new level in case you've
forgotten instead of the usual daily
wire studio we will be live streaming
our conversation on stage at the famous
ryman auditorium in nashville doing what
we do best talking suns this will be an
event and a live stream unlike any we
have ever done we are thrilled to be
able to share with all of you plus we're
making some exciting awesome
announcements really we're pumped about
it you're not going to want to miss it
so be sure to tune in join me countess
owens jeremy boring michael mills matt
walsh andrew clavin and our live
audience for a backstage like you have
never seen before tomorrow's live stream
begins at 8 30 pm eastern 7 30 pm
central head on over to dailywire.com or
dailywireyoutube to catch the show
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the
[Music]
nation righty so the fact is that all
the coved panic being driven by people
like dr anthony fauci it is bad science
and it's bad for the economy when i say
it's bad science what's kind of amazing
honestly is that we continue to trust
these public health figures after they
are wrong and wrong and wrong again you
would not trust your investment banker
the way that you trust these public
health figures really interesting
article from john tierney in the wall
street journal over the weekend talking
about how wrong dr anthony fauci was
about age remember he became famous for
being the guy fighting aids in the
government in the 1980s says john cena
when aids spread among gay men and
intravenous drug users four decades ago
it became conventional wisdom the plague
would soon devastate the rest of
american population in 1987 oprah
winfrey opened her show by announcing
quote research studies now project that
one in five listen to me hard to believe
one in five heterosexuals could be dead
of aids in the next three years the
prediction was outlandishly wrong but
she wasn't wrong in attributing the
scared of scientists one early alarmist
was dr anthony fauci who made national
news in 1983 with an editorial in the
journal of american medical association
jama the most prestigious american
journal
of medicine warning that aids could
infect even children because of the
possibility that routine close contact
as within a family household can spread
the disease
after criticism that he had inspired a
wave of hysterical homophobia dr fauci
who in 1984 began his current job as
director of the national institute of
allergy and infectious diseases promptly
pivoted 180 degrees declaring less than
two months after his piece appeared it
was absolutely preposterous to suggest
that aids could be spread by normal
social contact
but other supposed experts went on
warning erroneously that aids could
spread widely via toilet seats mosquito
bites and kissing
the cdc's own epidemiologists objected
to this message they were arguing that
resources should be focused on those who
are most at risk but they were overruled
by superiors who decided that presenting
aids as a universal threat was the best
way to win both attention and funding
the campaign succeeded because polls
showed americans became terrified of
being infected funding for aids
prevention surge much of it squandered
on measures to protect heterosexuals
and so as we have seen our public health
experts they are not good at this as it
turns out okay and there's some pretty
dire downstream effects to all of the
covid panic at this point in time
there are there are reports of soaring
energy costs that have been raising
concerns about u.s inflation in the
economy
we we have a huge bottleneck at the
ports and a lot of that is due to
staffing shortages according to the new
york times
the the
ports all around the world are now
involved in the great supply chain
disruption they're running out of places
to put things at the largest ports in
the united states as major reports
contend with a staggering pileup of
cargo but what seemed like a temporary
phenomenon a traffic jam that would
eventually dissipate is increasingly
viewed as a new reality
that could require a substantial
refashioning of the world's shipping
infrastructure
ships are waiting at sea for more than
nine days at the savannah port on a
recent afternoon more than 20 ships were
stuck in the queue anchored up to 17
miles off the coast in the atlantic such
lines have become common around the
globe from the more than 50 ships
marooned last week in the pacific near
la
to smaller numbers bobbing off terminals
in the new york area to hundreds way
laid off ports in china the turmoil in
the shipping industry and the broader
crisis in supply chains is showing no
signs of relenting it stands as annoying
source of worry throughout the global
economy challenging once hopeful
assumptions have a vigorous return to
growth as vaccines limit the spread of
the pandemic the disruption explains why
germany's industrial fortunes are
sagging why inflation is a a cause for
concern among central bankers why
american manufacturers are now waiting a
record 92 days on average to assemble
the parts and raw materials they need to
make their goods according to the
institute of supply management
on the surface the upheaval appears to
be a series of intertwined product
shortages because shipping containers
are in short supply in china factories
depending on chinese-made parts and
chemicals in the rest of the world have
had to limit production but the
situation at the port of savannah
attests to a more complicated and
insidious series of overlapping problems
it's not merely the goods or scares it's
that products are stuck in the wrong
places separated from where they are
supposed to be by stubborn and
constantly shifting barriers
the shortage of finished goods at
retailers represents the flip side of
the containers stacked on ships marooned
at sea and masked on the riverbanks the
pileup in warehouses is itself a
reflection of shortages of truck drivers
needed to carry goods to their next
destinations
the supply chain is overwhelmed and
inundated
says one of the supply chain managers in
one of the ports it's not sustainable at
this point everything is out of whack
again some of this is due to the massive
lack of labor
early this year when shipping prices
spiked and containers became scarce the
trouble was widely viewed as the
momentary results of pandemic lockdowns
with schools and offices shut americans
were stocking up on home office gear and
equipment for basement gyms drawing
heavily on factors in asia once life
reopened global shipping was supposed to
return to normal but half a year later
the congestion is worse with nearly 13
of the world's cargo shipping capacity
tied up by delays
many businesses now assume the pandemic
has fundamentally altered commercial
life in permanent ways those who might
never have shop for groceries or
clothing online have gotten a taste of
the convenience many are likely to
retain the habit maintaining pressure on
the supply chain
also the supply chain disruption has
imposed new frictions
because the upheaval on the seas is
slowing delivery it's limiting sales and
it's having significant downstream
effects and again a large part of this
is when you tell people they don't have
to go back to work they don't go back to
work according to the wall street
journal over the weekend the labor
department on friday reported another
disappointing month for employment the
problem wasn't a dearth of job the
question is where the hell are the
workers
employers added a mere 194 000 jobs in
september that's the second negative
monthly surprise in a row the
unemployment rate fell sharply to 4.8
percent from 5.2 but that's because 183
american 183 000 americans dropped out
of the workforce so we added as many
jobs as people who dropped out of the
workforce
there are now five million fewer
americans employed than before the
pandemic lockdowns three million of
those people have permanently left the
workforce
the number of americans unable to work
because their employer closed or lost
business dropped 600 000 from august
coveted cases declined by a third many
industries unaffected by the virus also
failed to add workers so what exactly is
happening
one possible culprit is government and
employer vax mandates that set
ultimatums for workers
president biden's vaccine order first
applied to nursing homes those lost jobs
this month many state and local school
districts have imposed mandates state
and local education employment fell 161
000. the white house claims the vaccine
mandates will boost job growth by
getting people comfortable with going
back to work but they're paying people
to stay home and a lot of the people who
would go back to work because they're
not worried are now out of jobs
democrats have also made quitting an
easier economic option says the wall
street journal pandemic enhanced
unemployment benefits ended in early
september but that was one week before
labor's monthly jobless survey ended
next month might provide better data but
there's still many other federal pay
financial payments that don't require
work including a 300 monthly allowance
per child food stamps and rental
assistance many people have saved some
of their transfer payments now democrats
are promising more
inflation may also be tilting the scale
to leisure instead of work
average hourly earnings are rising fast
they are seven point four percent at an
annualized rate but wage growth after
inflation has been declining because
food and energy prices are wildly up
the lack of workers is cr is creating a
drag on the economy slowing production
contributing to supply-side strains
shipped our back ships are backed up in
ports because there aren't workers to
unload and transport them where they
need to go and democrats of course are
planning trillions of dollars in new
taxes and spending in order to fix all
this meanwhile we have an energy
situation this is just back to the 1970s
here
the soaring energy prices i mean they're
really up crude oil is up 64 this year
it's at a seven year high natural gas
prices have doubled over the past six
months to a seventh year high heating
oil is up 68 this year prices at the
pump are up nearly a buck over the past
12 months to a national average of just
over three bucks a gallon coal prices
are at records this according to the
wall street journal and meanwhile the
biden administration is like what if we
made energy more expensive through green
mandates
for consumers it's like a tax says
economist catholic boasts jansec of
oxford econo oxford economics while
consumers will likely be squeezed the
energy price rise would have to be
extreme and prolonged to halt the
economic recovery but
more likely we'd see growth decelerate
more or a longer pause before growth
resumes
so we have shortages in supply chains we
have shortages of energy
we have increased taxes and increased
regulation and businesses who are not
investing as much because they don't
literally literally don't know how much
money they have to hold back before
taxes
and joe biden continues along this path
joe biden is just going to continue this
and it's it's a bold move cotton we'll
see how it works out for him
alrighty coming up a little bit later
today we'll have an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out the
michael knowles show today he discusses
how the biden administration is
canceling all remaining border wall
contracts you can hear more about that
story over on michael's show that's
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovets
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
two indiana children suffer heart
problems after accidentally being
injected with a covid vaccine joe biden
issues a first ever indigenous people's
day proclamation
from the white house and the new york
times says we need a new american flag
because they want a new american nation
check it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]